previously on raft you came back a
horrible monster there is more story on
this island and I want to get to you oh
[ __ ] here it is pound two seven five six
oh this is not in the game yet okay we
were sweet too honey
Oh B jar all right are we leaving this
island ernet and let me come how to get
B's sweep net the sweep man you go run
off and get us some B's baby I have not
any jars is that enough
what are you can use the bees yours
we're gonna make beehives in that way we
can make honey on the go
Jeff Bob give him the medal I don't know
for your outstanding service to our
craft and ordination I give you wait
stop the ceremony stop it we need we
need like ten more Beecher's you don't
get the duck until you get the B jars
how many more we need exactly seven more
we've got more potatoes than God himself
take that God so here God oh my god mark
we're gonna have so many goddamn
potatoes in here yeah I don't know why I
keep making the boy goes I was into
potatoes and nothing to do with them
Bob what if we do like a half circle
around the island and meet him on the
other beach give you that can you nap it
to the other side of the island mark
yeah I got 10 more bees a [ __ ] bear
there like that should no longer be
surprising at some point when you're on
the island where all there is as bears
and sometimes bees I've absorbed more
bear speed is that what does it every
time you kill a bear fast I've got 12
honey combs and 10 bees right now that's
pretty neat that's pretty neat what do
you want another award
yeah you owe me to try for another 20
bees or so I mean we're
we're gonna be in the other side of the
island at a certain amount of time you
got to decide for yourself you have a
certain amount of time to get over there
a note there's a trail of notes a trail
Oh what did you guys miss a whole
campsite what I left you with a simple
task of exploring the entire island
light bulb I don't know what I needed
that for where is that you're
outperforming mark right now I just ate
really and objectively outperforming
mark right now as teammate all right
what are you gonna do to make up for
mark I will see you and me on a boat no
one else get on your knees and tell him
you love him I was gonna I'm I am maybe
depending on what you want I'll be all
right with that all right cool here we
go perfect wow that's really concerning
look at my perspective on my stream mark
I think you'll really enjoy that you
shouldn't oh don't look no eye contact
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry oh hey
look the Bears I love you all right mark
yes that's what that's not have you guys
even read all the notes and I just got
you no not at all should I wear you
judge me it's done we're through
that's Note one all right father has a
new favorite we can't have that that's
number two and father has to make a
decision I know it won't be me I have
had done enough that's number three not
enough boat for all of us I'm sorry
that's number four the guilty lay
Restless we must be punished if we are
to rest that's that's last one
Wow sounds like I'm at least able rant
yeah of course why wouldn't it be comes
back and four ranger station I
appreciate you reading a gave me
something listen - why are you at the
ranger station Cheban unlocked fix Errol
was that no what do you do
I put a light bulb on a mannequin oh you
might have just reopened the latent
spirit of a long gone and dead soul
that's now gonna on us I I did that
friend it just a cheat I mean I like
achievements don't give it they're great
they're wonderful but shipments don't
put food on the table you're right you
right by mark I look great well I guess
arils good you get absolutely murder -
holy [ __ ] look man I wanted to look for
seaweed and turns out there's no seaweed
I've got news and I've got news I'm
right next to where the boat used to be
okay that wasn't the agreement the
ranger station is that's where Errol was
so I'm working my way back the other
side again damn it there any more
[ __ ] bees are these the [ __ ] bees
are you just angry I'm trying to get the
[ __ ] bees and the [ __ ] bees I'm
trying to get both trying to get my bees
and [ __ ] them too you know three
different angles I don't think you want
that okay come at me shark [ __ ] I see
where you're going for know oh one swap
of the machete and he goes away you
don't like you know like feel like wait
why are the sails up fine this again the
area that we never found I've found
twice been looking for bees I feel like
if you put a sail down all right hang on
I'm making a new sail farm I'm giving
the sails a home or they can live a
guilt-free
okay sail to their heart's content okay
mark you didn't happen to get like I
don't know
a map no did you why would I get a map
no someone says that you might be
holding out some information about a map
from us
from one of those notes no no no just uh
yeah I got a map here I guess Oh a map
you meant a map I thought wait said map
no I got a map here yeah there's a map
are you just okay with my brain again I
can't take many more brain [ __ ] what do
you mean well I'm looking at the map
what are you talking about
yeah wait I thought you were talking
about a map mark mark has a map I'm a
map yeah the matter yeah right so this
is them okay so I'm looking at the map
yeah where's the bees the bees aren't on
the map
no the bees might be on the map bees
might be on the map I might not be able
to get any more bees I don't know I
don't suck there's more bees I wouldn't
say they're bees everywhere I've seen no
more goddamn bees we saw a lot of bees
on the way in I don't know what you're
talking about
we're approaching the second beach mark
do you like the home I gave to your
sales where are they where are they oh
wow that is so cool the whole flock of
say no idea how you stacked them that
tightly Bob did we just skip over the
beach or should we pull on in there I
thought we were swinging all the way
back around cuz he didn't go there I
thought he was the only going half ziwei
wait where are you going
where we put you up you just want me to
go - I can go either way
let's go park up and was pulling in are
you guys move back to the other Beach
the original beach we don't know what
Beach this is this is not the beach the
where we dropped you off this is the
other beach this is a different Beach do
we follow the little creek around creek
the water water there's like a little
river that flows down here there's like
a listen team you do you see us I don't
see him where you seen what is that
there's a little thing in the water this
is the beach that we originally came
into okay I'm gonna follow this river
and see where this goes why would you do
that there's no River that comes to hear
[Laughter]
that wait why would you do that Bob
should we go find him I don't know
oh there's a shark here I'm in trouble
there's vines here we're where are you
under the sea what what I'm going back I
don't think this is where I want to be
no I don't think it's where you want to
be where are you of the river we don't
know where the river is all right
mark alright mark alright mark we're out
of here we're going to find and we're
going to find the river all right we
won't come to you you have to go to the
Wade wait but what I don't maybe
we all right I'm just gonna come find
you guys don't know where you guys are
we're navigating around to the river
area we're coming there but Bob woods I
don't know your River area I've been
there I've seen I've seen what he's
talking about I think yeah it's on the
outside of the island if we just keep
coming around we should get to where
he's at
okay I trust you Bob your captain and I
trust you a fish Bob here yeah okay we
are at the beach we dropped you off on
I'm coming back yeah this is the south
side beach all right I don't know
cardinal directions from my spear mama
tur but I'll try to head away the
direction that the moon is rising so
exactly literally the opposite area of
where I met yes you are as a beach we
were just yes we were just there no you
couldn't have been here cuz the ref
wouldn't fit but I get what you're
saying you were around this part of the
island so don't worry I'm coming home
baby
Bob I want to revisit your idea that we
could leave them behind [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god how was that I'm gonna kill a
bear and I don't really have a whole lot
of spear left okay how is that our
problem I'm gonna take a nap mark all
right taking that I'll see you yeah see
you man Wade I'm almost back calm calm
we're gonna get there and be on the
wrong side and absolutely not be back oh
no what 100% knew this would happen you
guys oh my god he's calm us here got it
got it got it all right okay why are we
going are we had a few oh we're out of
fuel you guys thought you could leave me
I'm too fast mark
homey my main man yo its up come to Papa
Bear way and here you go right cool
thanks but problem we can't build the
Beehive we don't have clay you left the
honey get some clay hey you come oh
thanks man
alright cool and we're off baby back to
the island I miss it
we are chug a lug in we know what if
we're gonna be back in long-distance
mode you're gonna put the captain's
going back in the purse alright you
captain deserves it captain my captain
it's assuming the position oh my god
Wade you're a miracle I love you I love
you too I did not I love you I love you
sir
I love you with me I love you finally
after the whole serial of you under my
skin guys look at my captain's rug I got
a flying carpet up here perch Oh God
goodbye alright actually I think the rug
is causing me to not know right there
that's where the rug goes silent all
right you guys want to do a regular type
island yeah we could use some clay yeah
we could use some clay yeah we could
dock dock up over here and strip this
land of any valuable resource and leave
it to rot in hell that's what I like to
hear that's the captain I know and love
captaining you all elected
democratically did we do what I have a
mandate to lead oh okay cool I'm down oh
I know much I have so much meat tell me
about your meat tell me are you Rahl
that's good I can't believe I had
exactly I'm awesome
well saying words there any seaweed in
this ocean and whatnots there's an ocean
of seaweed here this is good why is the
shark only on me get out of here
no no I don't see no shark it's a smooth
sailing in these oceans
okay shark whoa we're halfway this came
back to me someone oh the Sharks coming
for me bros oh no it missed me
hey mom hey thanks sharks cry baby
sharks coming for bait how did I get to
yeah I'm kind of carrying Bob back to
the boat so okay
carrying Bob he's dead I got in covers
turning you know I've been her covers
dated before yeah
summer goes [ __ ] all right this shark
is tough
freeway I'm gonna keel is a lot faster
freeway yeah yeah well if we [ __ ] them
together but we also kill them after I
said freeway not three-way were you at
you shark be it geez circling in the
shallows like oh he's startling his own
demise
got it got him almost bet I bet come
over here you piece of garbage oh he
came over here his piece of garbage all
right Oh actually if he hits me again
I'm gonna die mark are you here no I
left you to it why
I'm gonna die weird of the Stern's of
tabled I'm here to help
oh how the turns of tables
oh of course there is and whoop I
thought I had a jumping slam on him here
we go roof would have been so cool if
that would work got a bunch of palm
seeds and stuff from this died beauties
on the boat get out here
loser do I have enough to make a honey
quick he's dead alright I don't know how
the B ish this is gonna make our boat
but beehive baby alright what do we do
about it I have made it gonna be your
honey I really thought there was gonna
be more fanfare to this there is not I
have a bees all right 15 jars of bees in
this and there are no bees I hear
there's no bees you okay mark if the
other thing have no B then why right
right
why would it to make Waffen to go up or
maybe I put marks you do it wrong boom
that's not right I don't understand
everyone my chat screaming flowers
flower there's no flowers oh there is
flowers is that what you need flowers
for in this game
we put beef ours you understand now
Margaret so Milly
yeah I just I plant flowers that makes a
lot of sense in Minecraft with flower
things a definitely a thing
yeah minecraft is how real life is hey
hey hey hey hey I saw you built a house
your first house is yeah and minecraft I
did and it's lovely
don't you minecraft series when
everything boys don't you dare right
here your boys is out here mark do you
hear that
I don't care where my here about your
boys I don't care about where my boys
are I don't care you four episodes to
build a single [ __ ] house you don't
want to kill do not don't you dare
we built the house every day Bob had a
treehouse every episode of don't mind
crap
this is true don't you dare so we're
Penn I'm an idiot so what does that make
you
episode 4 could have been something
interesting but you know look if you can
build a house again look look guys I
need you no apparently not that's what
you just said you said it marking on us
I am leaving the stage for this bit no
quit the bit I quit can't do it like
with the BS and yes and the bit has been
quit and I quit this bit too bad man we
could load it up looking out like horse
tranquilizer minecrafter Sancta but here
a bit dude
howdy hardcore tranquilize you know I
didn't think about that the potential
the sheer raw magnificent potential
nobody do people were watching our
stream and we're just waiting for an
excuse can do horse tranquilizers this
will be pretty for the bees I guess so
do we need to plant like a dirt thing to
plant flowers in I don't know how the
flowers Oh God no no no
what have I done please oh god oh god I
ruined it I was gonna make it pretty for
the fees oh my no no we could we could
just title it sober minecraft and but
you know marked it as solo instead so
yeah I did so it what you can do better
what what is it you know just call you
off of the fact to get four episodes to
build a house sue you because I own the
rights to the idea of playing Minecraft
on YouTube although your royal balls
must be incredible you have no idea
dozens of dollars have been rolling in
for decades now dollars so marks people
are calling out some spoilers about your
your series and about how your house
sucks
yeah how about your house sucking a big
a it does not your booze I found
something to do with all of our enormous
amounts of potatoes we can put it in the
bio harvester so I'll just keep the
potatoes going and then I'll leave a
chest by the other place and it will
serve as our eternal perpetual fuel
shark coming in shark coming in looks
like you guys got it got it
twitchy McGillicuddy over here ain't
gonna but I got it mmm-hmm oh I'm here
I'm helping I'm fine how are you twitchy
zelans is what you are good for the
environment you're twitching yeah how
does that sell oh yeah you explain that
one I just did I said it there for its
fact
all right you right he did say it on the
internet even though twitch I'm so
scared to be near you it's the bear head
to the bear head also it's just like
it's very unpleasant to look at oh sorry
almost knocked it we're halfway in time
you say the word whoa does not
legitimately give you cause just to say
that song
Patrick static Patrick whenever I did I
said that one time he made that joke and
I can't unhear it and then we were we
were talking and he said someone's like
oh say can you see
so now those bows pop in my head and I
say oh ho or if I go woah in any way I
can't stop alright biofuel is being made
this way did the whole bit and we were
all kind of like processing it and you
were just like alright this thing I'm
doing honestly the longer the more I was
ignoring and tuned it up by the end of
it I didn't even realize Wade was saying
anything
it's that's kind of my existence the
last eight years
anyway what's being made but I don't
know how to get it to the do thing
there's a pipe like models or something
oh I don't know we are out of planks for
like cooking I don't know do we need to
do to get chugging yeah alright I'm
gonna get this party on the road baby
tank where's this beehive I'm gonna see
oh here it is yeah it's nice it's
actually very lovely and we were
supposed to go up and take honey comes
out of it right I don't know
are there honeycomb available yeah it's
got some look to it right now and it
says e to pick up honeycomb I'll take it
if you want to take a look and see if it
looks do any different oh it's absorbing
oh it's dripping drop e yeah you can
take it yeah - money comes we come to
put in like one of these boxes near it
Oh what the hell this thing's huge
Oh interesting well there's the tank and
then I could connect the pipe here so I
got the pipe but how do I get this to go
into the tank
why is there something at the top
there's something at the top wait that's
me what is this oh no wait wait is what
I said I think maybe the biofuel needs
to be a floor above this tank because
there seems to be like some kind of
podium you put water on top it looks
like maybe oh no you just pick up
biofuel okay so I picked up file filled
oh you just place it in you don't you
don't do anything weird with it wrong
I liked Mark's fantastical version yeah
what can you say what can you say what
can you say I wish you were true but it
is not it is not true why do you have an
accident no it is not true but the
biofuel does seem to crank a link a lot
of stuff so maybe I could hold it
another Island of our lives a biggest
one a biggish one let's got a lot of
trees at least and it's got a lot of
trees this could be your goat it could
be a little bit also we never fish
medical puffer fish I've never seen a
puffer fish
not once get your there dude I filled
these bad boys
oh dude we're never gonna need to burn
wood for engines again oh really
we're so good Wow hell yeah I want to
thank the team for this I want to thank
the team for this it was really a team
effort that I deserve all the credit for
I am so thankful that I am here for you
you are lucky to have me on your team
and frankly I think you are blessed
every time you get to look at my face
you're welcome
everybody is welcome great job dear mark
although the problem of the biofuel is
it may need a lot more honey don't you
just put potatoes in it what's honey for
you need potatoes and honey for some
reason I'm not a hundred percent sure
well we have a hive Oh should we catch
more bees from our own high probably not
Oh
swing your net around it really bang
yeah I bet they bang oh that is oh that
is a whoa that is an interesting Island
yeah this is a fancy little island we've
got here oh but also unfortunately I
might have to go we just got here I know
I know we have so much to do
I know we do but cliffhanger though just
like the last island we have a new
island to look out for next to next
hello I'm late ha ha ha I just what
they've got too many bears my
twitchiness it's starting to apply to
all of me alright alright be ready on
the anchor and me hearties standing back
not yet I would maybe this corner anchor
[Music]